five four three
two
one
hey everybody
ryan right over here i just wanted to
say thank you i had to cut the live
stream event short yesterday and that's
why i'm doing this now so i thought i'd
make it a little bit fun for everyone
um for those who are going to be joining
in late i hope you guys can help like
re-explain what's going on basically the
mission impossible i've been waiting for
this trailer
wait i forgot to hit record so i'm gonna
redo this whole introduction right now
um that's the only time i ever hit
re-record is because i forget to do the
introduction so hold on
this is gonna look silly
hey guys ryan right here this is the
second time i'm doing this so for those
joining in late good for you guys
i have been waiting for this trailer to
drop for the longest [ __ ] time now
mission impossible five i ever since
it's weird you know some people really
prefer the first one but it was mission
impossible three for me that was really
that run three for me i like to go pp oh
my god i like to eat [ __ ]
uh
this is a live streaming event uh right
now fans are
jumping in having a good old time
talking amongst each other and so what
this is gonna be a little bit different
i'm pretty excited for this uh i'm gonna
be
basically doing a live reaction
for this i am unfortunately can't show
the fans the mission impossible 5 video
so
all you guys are gonna have to look at
my face the entire time instead
see there's a laptop right here i'm
gonna keep the laptop in the shot
so all you pretty folks will have to
look at my face instead throughout this
entire video
um but before i get into the video uh
just for the fans i just wanted to say
thank you guys for jumping in at such
last notice minute whatever the phrase
is you guys are [ __ ] awesome we hit
90 000 subscribers thank you guys so
much every single subscriber really does
count like i view each and every one of
you as an individual person so thank you
guys it's crazy it's like i imagine like
what if i were to look at 90 000 people
that would be [ __ ] insane so
here we go uh mission impossible uh the
franchise i love
part three is actually i might say that
one's my favorite i love the more
grounded more dark tone they went for it
was really old like personal story but
part four is definitely the most fun out
of them all ghost protocol [ __ ]
rocked uh this last this guy who's
directing it he's worked with tom cruise
several times before um
i edge of tomorrow's one of my favorite
[ __ ] movies of last year
but at the same time i wasn't a big fan
of his direction and jack reacher i know
tom cruise was satisfied with it so
here we go
let's do this
i'm about to watch it you guys will be
able to hear it
but you won't be able to see it
so
hopefully you've already seen the
trailer already
or you can just hit play in 10
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one i'm [ __ ] stoked and i heard alec
baldwin's in this
too want you to choose your next words
very carefully whereas hunt
nice
[Music]
nice
[Music]
where are you syndicated
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
whoa
that was really him hanging from the
[ __ ] airplane
holy [ __ ]
you could tell that was him and you
could tell that was i mean if that's cgi
that's amazing [ __ ] cgi
um
well it's so different watching the
trailer with knowing a whole bunch of
people are watching it right now
it's like it feels like you're in a
[ __ ] group with a bunch of people so
your energy gets jacked up um
yeah dude [ __ ] that was cool i love
what i'm seeing so far these are my
initial thoughts uh what i want to do is
uh get you guys asking questions and
hearing your opinions on it and we can
go back and forth on uh what we thought
of the trailer all of us i thought that
would be really fun like an interactive
experience so
i want to just give my initial thoughts
i love the tone of it so far it seems
like a hybrid of like part three and
four because four brought it back to
the fun spy you know espionage type of
vibe but three had more of a dark tone
and it felt more personal and more
intense so i feel like they are taking
both of the best mission impossibles and
putting putting it together like it
looks executed very well you know tom
cruise has this darkness going on in his
intensity i love seeing what's going on
with simon pegg how he's uh you know
more involved in the actual field like
he's dressed up like a british spy has
his glasses and alec baldwin playing a
tough guy at the agency
what other role would you want the guy
to do and tom cruise is so [ __ ] sexy
i totally sucked this guy's [ __ ] yeah
you know i had my doubts but seeing the
the way it's all captured it looks like
a darker version of ghost protocol which
that's pretty [ __ ] sweet and tom
cruise's hair
doesn't look that bad i thought i wasn't
going to like it based off of still but
i like his hair i like his hair kind of
looks like a little catholic boy but i
like his hair
anyway guys so let's chime in what did
you guys
what did you guys think of the trailer
so apparently this was a teaser
now i feel like a [ __ ] idiot
um
okay well
what did you guys think of the teaser
that's easier than me it seemed like it
could be a perfect trailer
all right
the rogue nation title i am ninja panda
yeah the rogue ninja title road nation
road ninja i was reading someone has a
ninja name rogue nation is such a cool
title yes i uh i i like this the idea
too of having
a
anti-agency that's it's pretty much like
you know the
imf is that what they're called
or is it int imf i forgot wait what is
it i forgot you guys are here well
what's the what is it imf
um
yeah i've been having tom cruise's
agency have like an equal agency but
they're the bad guys that's that's a
clever plot actually i like that's what
i mean it brings it back to feeling a
little bit more personal
they call me kkp
said i love how tom cruise ups the ante
in his stunts last movie he was climbing
the tallest building this time he's on a
fn airplane whoa [ __ ]
yeah i mean tom cruise keeps getting
older but what makes him cool is he's
really trying to prove that he's not old
and he keeps doing life dangerous things
you know putting his life on edge for
the sake of entertaining us to be like i
really am not old please still let me
have a career
no tom cruise is this [ __ ] he's one of
my favorite actors
um oh [ __ ] no there was a good question
it just disappeared
where'd it go
where'd it go
you know i gotta say something
i normally don't do teasers for trailers
that are already being released because
i don't think there's a point to it it's
like
it's kind of a weird crossroads because
there's trailer reactions
and you know we i turn them into trailer
reviews so it's good to like actually
have it in front of me but
when
there's a time where you had to wait for
it to release in a movie theater in
order to see it now that's like a rare
imax experience or something like with a
nolan film
with
with um
sorry i'm trying to gather my thoughts
here i'm a little sick by the way and uh
i'm a little distracted to even my
girlfriend's at a photo shoot right now
or she might be taking sexy photos and
i'm not there to know who these guys are
bastards
sons of evil [ __ ]
anyway yeah so this trailer is something
that's really showing me like
man tom cruise is
i'm just so psyched for it man this is
why i have jump cuts because i'm always
i get so caught up in my emotions
oh yeah but no like teaser for for
trailers come on like we don't really
need that do we
how would chris flower bow asked how
would you rate the first four mission of
possible movies from your favorite to
least favorite um it would go three four
one two
one one one zero five ahmed said he
looks a little old well he is over 50 uh
ahmed so it does make sense
nato del toro said it was awesome but it
feels like it's trying to imitate what
brad bird did in ghost protocol
um i don't think about imitate i think
it's more about like honoring the tone
but i can see why you might feel that
way billy lawrence said i think that you
have the best reactions ryan well thanks
man
david knew and i am replying
southern place says [ __ ] you and your
pubic hair why would you want to [ __ ] my
pubic hair
billy lawrence said
the plot twist is that the rogue nation
is actually the real rejects who are
rejected from the imf their leader ryan
wright is the main antagonist and
there's an epic showdown late in the
film that's true and then tom cruise
makes me suck his dick in revenge
eliana ramirez said i love you oh is
that a lady
i have a girlfriend so no however she's
taking sexy photos for guys right now
spalding's reject said would you let tom
cruise give you a rim job absolutely
[ __ ] i don't care what conflict it would
cause my girlfriend
nato del toro said regarding stunts he's
the american jackie chan that's a very
that's you know what
that is true
because jackie chan
was a famous famous dude who put his
life at risk you know it's
and so when someone who's that famous
and really is consistent with doing
their own stunts i mean the only thing
that this guy that jackie chan really
had on him would not the only thing but
jackie chan also um was known for not
using wires all the time there were
times where he did but tom cruise
usually uses wires
solomon play says do you think the
mission will be the most impossible in
this movie i certainly hope so i
certainly hope so
[Music]
do you think this will be the last
mission impossible with tom cruise
you know studios are always like okay
there's already a thing happening and
the gunman really is like beating it to
the ground but there's already a thing
happening where
actors over 50 are doing action movies
like liam neeson really established that
there's the expendables i as long as
this movie does well i think they'll
keep tom cruise on for as long as
possible
trailer reactions go [ __ ] yourself for
saying that about veronica you son of a
[ __ ]
zanda zandar bro do you think mission
impossible will be a six part trilogy at
the end of the story
uh that would be a really interesting
take on it sure i think
they could end on a five but i think six
would be a good number two
brendan egan says something perfect
every year tom gets older in his action
movies he gets younger
so freaking true
it's all that botox
eliana ramirez said who would you cast
to be
you in a movie um well the guy from
inception that everyone says i look like
ricardo rojo for harrison how is it to
be ryan right it's good my big [ __ ]
takes care of me most places i go
emma varaki was asking basically
yeah what is uh my opinion on if they
uh changed tom cruise to another actor
well the the original rumor is tom
cruise would eventually leave and jeremy
rare would take over but i don't think
jeremy renner has exactly the same star
intense presence i'm not saying they
need to duplicate tom cruise but you
know something along the lines where
they could really carry the
entertainment factor or or they just
replace them with a really good ensemble
knight missed said do you think they
might decide to replace tom cruise when
they decide to make the next mission
impossible like have him train the next
generation and go on one last mission
uh
that is a good way to put it yeah i
would prefer if he gets killed off
because mission impossible so they can
do like a mission impossible 10 where he
comes back from the dead and they're
like what i thought you died
one one one zero five comment if someone
had to replace tom cruise at mission
impossible who would you prefer it to be
um i think i would like it to be oh
that's a great question
i can't believe i never thought of that
um
hmm
would i like it
to obey
[ __ ]
how do i not have an answer for that
[ __ ]
alright
yes i do think andrew martin and i will
meet in person
dude it just keeps
like he keeps skipping all these
questions
like
every single time i i like try to reload
this it just like jumps down and then
all the other questions come in that's
the hard part about keeping up with
everyone's questions because i don't
choose to skip
my favorite tom cruise movie
um it's it's a toss-up between my nordie
airport and edge of tomorrow although
it's not my favorite movie but his
performance and collateral is one of my
favorites of him
i'm reading them directly off youtube
right now
joshua garland said what is her personal
intake on cgi well i think a lot of
people are not so happy with cgi these
days because
cgi has to be used for the right type of
film you know if you can get away with
practical effects or keeping it real
people are really going to prefer that
so when you use cgi to like save money
or make the job easier that's when
people really don't like it
i do like the last samurai it's not one
of my favorite performances it is but i
do like it
ryan fitzsimmons said i love how the
missions are always possible what if
this one is actually impossible and they
just go okay well [ __ ] it let's get a
new career that would be a funny like
vine or something
okay well the questions seem to be
stopping about mission impossible five
and this is a mission impossible five
video
so um i'm going to end this i've been
recording now for
um quite some time and i'm gonna upload
this video tomorrow gonna edit it so
thank you guys for tuning in and helping
the review this is why i like it because
you know like a lot of the time when i
do a trailer review a lot of questions
come in and so i don't really know like
what what are what are other things that
people might want me to discuss so doing
this makes it fun
um i'm not gonna do another live event
for a while
except for tomorrow when the official
trailer drops so i'll see you then
take care bye bye
thank you guys for tuning in too by the
way i [ __ ] love you guys 90 000 was
[ __ ] amazing so seriously thank you
you